gbagbo bonjour à tous j'ai vous
présentez un domaine passionnant celui
de la réalité virtuelle et dans le cadre
psychologique c'est à dire comment on
utilise ce support ce média pour traiter
les patients qui souffrent de troubles
mentaux
vous pouvez être fiers car le terme réel
et virtuel est inventée par un français
antonin artaud qui était metteur en
scène la définition actuelle c'est celle
ci c'est à dire qu'il s'agit pour
l'arrêter virtuelle d'un ensemble de
technologies ordinateurs tracker casque
qui permet aux individus d'interagir en
temps réel efficacement et de manière
indue t-il avec un environnement en 3d
et ceci à l'aide de ses sens à turenne
et de ses compétences
un concept de clés qu'on retrouve dans
la réalité virtuelle si la sensation
d'être là vous êtes dans un autre
environnement un environnement qui
n'existe pas qui était construit par des
hommes par des ordinateurs et pourtant
vous avez l'impression d'exister
vous pouvez aussi vous posez la même
question dans la réalité qu'est ce qui
vous fait penser vous existez maintenant
au théâtre liberté vous y réfléchirez
statham easy voile évidemment il ya une
très grosse évolution technologique les
premiers casques en fait été était
fonctionner avec des ordinateurs
gigantesque de la taille d'un immeuble
on le voit ici suspendu en fait
l'orateur prend tous les étages
supérieurs
c'était dans les années 60 vous voyez
que c'est déjà assez anciens tout de
même évidemment les compagnies aériennes
et l'armée se sont emparés de ce
principe pour entraîner leurs pilotes et
la nasa pour entraîner ses astronautes
ça c'est le matin que vous pouvez
trouver aujourd'hui si vous voulez
plongée des personnes dans des
environnements de synthèse que vous avez
créé et est ce qu'on utilise à l'hôpital
pour traiter ces patients
vous avez aussi un autre principe qu'on
utilise en ce moment donc un mini qui
est le cas yves là vous ne portez même
pas de casque
c'est la pièce entière qui est un écran
géant
chaque mur et d'un écran et vous voyez
ici c'est une personne qui a peur des
hauteurs regardez bien sa position elle
est effrayée par la situation car là où
à peu près elle traverse un pont de bois
au dessus d'un vide de 50 mètres et non
il n'y a pas de piquant mais déjà ça
suffit pour lui faire part voit donc le
matériel classique c'est céda vrai ça
donc le casque etc
pour ce qui est des logiciels alors
évidemment là aussi fort montée
relativement à la fin les deux les 110
parce que certains d'entre vous ont joué
à ce jeu et voici les jeux qui ont suivi
on voit le graphisme a évolué c'est
magnifique un nuage les avions c'est
super je suis sûr que vous êtes en
extase devant un tas graphisme et oui
c'est cette nouvelle fier et on voit
l'évolution avec la 3d isométrique avec
les axones ici donc on a des liens
programmes en 3d dans l'association
espace et on continue avec sur amstrad
bruce lee donc là déjà les personnages
sont plus reconnaissables
on voit nettement ici bruce lee un bien
sûr et aura des les montagnes enneigées
ya beaucoup plus de détails
c'est déjà plus chatoyant on passe à
shadow of the beast voyez bien qu'ici il
ya déjà un net progrès on distingue bien
le personnage et des scrolling le
paysage défile sur plusieurs dimensions
bon déjà c'est plus attrayant à l'oeil
mais si pas encore réaliste assis dedans
n'était pas y croire et bien sûr
l'inénarrable street fighter sur le
conatus passer des heures qui est déjà
beaucoup plus taillé au niveau des
textures on voit envoyé de l'ombre on
voit la profondeur le fameux mode 7 qui
permet de se différencier de la
profondeur donc on évolue
la 3d fait là réellement son apparition
avec resident evil sur le playstation
donc là on voit que les personnages sont
dans 3 est donc là vous évolué vous
évoluez dans un environnement qui n'est
donc plus détaillée et avec encore plus
de profondeur
mais malgré tout vécu encore c'est pas
avoir très très faim chêne mou sur
dreamcast donc là vous pouvez voir que
c'est déjà bien plus détaillée encore
avec des textures qui sont beaucoup plus
fine
personnage commence à vraiment bien
reconnaître alors là c'est flower donc
là c'est pour montrer que les jeux c'est
pas toujours de la violence contre
orléans fait une brise et cette brise va
en fait tourbillonner et ainsi vous
pouvez détacher les pétales de fleurs et
contre les pétales de fleurs dans un pré
voyez ceux qui pensent que jeux vidéo
sont violents là nous avons donc les
derniers jeux avec uncharted
regardez bien comme c'est magnifique
maintenant le niveau de réalisme par
rapport à ce que je vous ai montré avant
ou à bien son nom brême l'est pas en
fait qu'il a laissé les empreintes sur
le sable le détail au niveau des
textures les ombres portées le dr niveau
des personnages
bon c'est maintenant c'est très réaliste
donc en résumé 1982 pitfall 2
d'activision rabais bien ça que vous
aventure vous êtes là c'est un chacal
très dangereux il a l'air furieux la
forêt qui est luxuriante magnifique et
on passe 30 ans plus tard
regardez bien à uncharted c'est
évidemment la différence est énorme on
voit les pourrait gigantesque en effet
en terme de réalisme dans ce domaine et
est-ce qu'on va exploiter dans la
réalité virtuelle parce que notre but
est de faire croire aux patients que ce
qu'ils voient est réel pour déclencher
des émotions donc des programmes sont
des programmes de réalité virtuelle vous
pouviez voir maison vous pouvez utiliser
des programmes de jeux vidéo si vous
n'êtes pas beaucoup d'argent
ou vous pouvez d'idées pour un pro qui
sont beaucoup moins abordables après
vous pouvez créer donc avec deluxe et 3
des différents types d'objets là j'avais
créé à partir c'est dans l'australien
partir du métro australien j'avais créé
ce modèle car j'avais des patients qui
avaient peur de prendre le métro
oui j'avais pris d'échelle et c'est très
drôle avec mon maître devant tout le
monde
à la gare c'était pas mal la réalité
virtuelle donc que tu utilisé dans de
nombreux domaines chez limitèrent pour
l'entraînement les nanos chimie les
chirurgiens pour les entraîner les jeux
vidéo
l'ingénierie et le design dans mon
domaine c'est en psychiatrie qu'on
utilise alors en psychiatrie et en
psychologie et psychothérapie donc on
utilise principalement pour être blank
cieux phobie troubles obsessionnels
compulsifs stress post-traumatique mais
comment savoir d'études pour les
troubles des conduites alimentaires
les addictions et même la schizophrénie
ce qui paraît un peu inconcevable pas
schizophrène la réalité ça peut être un
peu difficile
donc ça c'est les pathologies contre est
régulièrement avec la réalité virtuelle
alors lacoste aux phobies
l'arachnophobie la peur de prendre
l'avion
le stress post traumatique si jamais
vous attaquer par un dinosaure ce qui
arrive souvent
la has et concerne les entrepreneurs la
peur panique de la bourse évidemment ça
faut traiter ça aussi parce qu'on parle
entrepreneuriat mais après faut passer
derrière au niveau psychologique
n'entreprenez ans j'en vois un voilà
donc en quoi
quel intérêt en fait alors le problème
évidemment comme vous avez une phobie
c'est que vous évitez ces lieux dont les
personnes prennent pas l'avion prennent
pas l'ascenseur ils prennent l'escalier
c'est bon pour leur corps mais bon si
c'est 30 étages voilà donc il ya un
apparaît très important au niveau social
si vous êtes très timide vous avez une
phobie sociale et que vous allez pas un
rendez vous romantique et bien vous
n'avez pas pouvoir sortir avec cette
belle actrice dont vous rêviez et c'est
donc évidemment vous avez les
traitements vous pouvez utiliser les
bennes daudet et pillé la machine à
bonheur etc
mais les effets sont sur le court moyen
terme car dès que vous arrêtez ces
traitements et bien vous rajouter c'est
l'intérêt de la psychothérapie
dans le cadre de la thérapie cognitivo
comportementale on expose donc le
patient à ce à quoi il a peur mais de
manière progressive
si vous avez peur de prendre l'avion eh
bien on va faire un petit vol marseille
corse par exemple on n'en fera pas un
marseille australie par exemple à vous
traumatiser votre patient c'est fini
avant d'accoucher ou donc voilà le
problème c'est que crée ainsi dans
l'exposition niveau donc c'est ce que je
disais vous vous exposez le problème
c'est que dans la réalité vous avez du
mal à contrôler les événements est ce
que vous pouvez contrôler une couvrance
pas marché est-ce que vous pouvez
contrôler les turbulences dans le ciel à
moins qu'il ya un dieu parmi vous et ça
il faudra en discuter
c'est impossible voilà le problème aussi
c'est que si vous accompagnez votre
patient prendre l'avion ça coûte très
cher bon s'il est très riche si vous
êtes le psychothérapeute une star ça
peut être une solution mais tous vos
patients ne seront pas des stars
n'auront pas les moyens de vous payer
pour vous prenez l'avion avec eux par
exemple donc un printemps porhel vous
perdez beaucoup de temps et un prêt
financier en termes de coûts donc ce
n'est pas réalisable alors les
événements incontrôlables dont je vous
ai parlé ça peut être un problème
évidemment de monde ainsi vous
accompagnez votre passion dans le métro
et que ce jour là il ya beaucoup de
personnes et bien c'est fini
là vous traumatiser la vous aggravez sa
phobie si vous aussi vous citer les
turbulences en avion là c'est pareil ou
si vous venez dans un ascenseur pour
qu'il s'entraine pour les claustrophobes
par exemple ceux qui ont par des lieux
fermés etc à une panne technique c'est
fini aussi là vous créez une attaque de
panique donc on a des problèmes à
contrôler la réalité un donc c'est ce
que propose justement en fait la réalité
virtuelle car avec la réalité virtuelle
vous c'est vous qui contrôlez la réalité
vous appuyez sur un bouton et un peu de
monde
un bouton il ya beaucoup de monde encore
un bouton il ya une turbulence et c'est
donc l'idée c'est que vous remplacez la
réalité par d'estimé qui sont
artificiellement créée par l'ordinateur
donc là on voit de sept personnes qui
portent le casque de réalité virtuelle
que nous avons utilisée pour nous et
notre étude est qu'elle est isolée en
fait de l'extérieur finalement pas façon
à l'immerger complètement dans cet
environnement virtuel
la toute première étude qui a été fait
dans ce domaine est de 92 quand même
plus de 20 ans sur la peur des hauteurs
la crau phobie le but tout comme
l'exposition classique en exposant le
patient de manière progressive bien sûr
et bien vous arrivez ainsi
à l'extinction de la peur l'avantagé du
coup ses contrôles et ses confidences et
parce que vous êtes dans le bureau vous
pouvez faire un meilleur graduation des
environnements vous pouvez répéter cette
expérience
si vous voulez en mars et los angeles en
réalité virtuelle on peut le faire dix
fois si vous vous laissez aucune
importance vous pouvez le monitorer
évidemment en mettant des électeurs qui
vont mesurer le rythme cardiaque si vous
vous intéressez aux mesures
physiologiques et une meilleure
motivation c'est sûr que la personne va
dire vidéo si génial allons-y alors que
si vous vous doutez bien l'avouer devoir
rentrer dans un vrai ascenseur par ce
n'est déjà moins enthousiaste et comme
je vous le dis il ya une réduction du
temps consacré et du coup évidemment il
y a déjà de nombreuses études qui ont
montré l'efficacité la réalité virtuelle
en fait dans le domaine de la
psychothérapie notamment pour ces
pathologies donc la part de conduire la
peur des araignées la peur de la foule
la peur des moteurs depuis déjà un bon
moment
alors il ya des domaines plus
expérimentaux comme justement l'état car
le propre des toc c'est que c'est ça
varie d'une personne à l'autre alors
créé un environnement pour une seule
personne
ça c'est pratiquement impossible pour
l'instant en tout cas à moins de faire
des patients des créateurs ce qui
arrivera peut être dans le futur mais il
est quand même déjà quelques études qui
ont montré l'efficacité notamment dans
l'obsession de l'ordre et du rangement
le stress post traumatique qu'il ya de
grandes études qui ont été faites par
les américains sur les vétérans la
guerre du vietnam et qui ont montré que
c'était très efficace les patients
étaient moins anxieux plus récemment en
irak et aussi pour les traumatisés du 11
septembre qui représente une grande
population
voilà donc on parlait d' aliments sans
gluten avec le thème certes mais vous
avez en tout les cas des anorexiques et
boulimiques vont pouvoir être étaient
ils ont des primes de représentation de
l'image corporelle des problèmes qui
sont liés aux stimuli avoir un gros pot
nutella c'est toujours bien tentant non
du coup vous allez les exposer sa
situation donc des placards remplis de
la en 3d bien sûr et est également vous
allez les aider à changer leur façon de
percevoir leurs corps avaient des
représentations en 3d leur corps et ça
fonctionne c'est à démontrer sur une
étude de 120 sujet enfin c'est
d'effluents parmi vous et bien c'est
utilise également dans le domaine de
l'alcoolisme et de la consommation donc
de nicotine même principe vous exposer
le sujet à des stimuli
voulait tenter qui vont les pousser à
fumer donc les le bar la cuisine
restaurant la plage conduire la voiture
etc
à la pause café et ainsi vous leur
apprenez vos les entraîner à ne pas
fumer justement dans ces situations
virtuelles après les applique ça la
réalité naturellement parce que c'est un
intérêt après c'est d'appliquer les
principes à la réalité
donc les différentes études ont démontré
qu'il y avait une diminution du corps et
ving de kolding c'est l'impulsion de
vouloir consommer le produit addictif
l'imposant parfumé etc voilà pour les
schizophrènes race est très très
expérimental il faut être très très
prudent parce qu'ils ont tendance à
confondre la réalité avec la virtualité
alors si en plus vous mettez un
environnement virtuel voilà c'est fini
c'est jack nicholson donc donc très
important ça on commence à voir les
études mais qui se font essentiellement
dans le cadre des compétences sociales
comment discuter avec un avatar virtuel
pour après l'appliquer dans la vie comme
en discuter avec une vraie personne et
ya une amélioration des montres et des
compétences sociales mais ça reste
encore très expérimentale les
inconvénients il faut parler aussi quand
même votre objectif le sidekick naissent
parfois les gens l'ont un peu le mal des
transports
s'ils bougent trop vite dans la réalité
virtuelle les myopes aussi peuvent avoir
des problèmes pour les mobiles très
sévère les épilepsies photosensible
comme les japonais avec le jeu vidéo qui
avait eu une crise chez les enfants il
ya un problème générationnel parfois les
personnes très âgées pour avoir discuté
pour l'utiliser et on va pour l'instant
ça reste encore confiné au laboratoire
aux universités aux grands instituts est
temps que maintenant tout le monde peut
utiliser la réalité virtuelle
alors je vais voir si je peux faire
fonctionner la vidéo
j'ai vous commentez donc cette
représentation artistique artistique du
protocole de ready verte qu'on a mis en
place pour traiter les patients qui sont
agoraphobe donc peur du métro peur de la
foule par de prendre l'avion par des
parkings souterrains
c'est une représentation artistique bien
sûr du patient c'est le vrai passion
quand vous vous avez remarqué
donc quand on re des passions il c'est
une étude scientifique donc fait
particulièrement sérieux et très
systématique quand on fait ses études
parce qu'après faut les pubs livres etc
non d'abord on a fait un an que les
menaces ou par téléphone pour voir s'il
était effectivement agoraphobe à ce que
vous avez part de conduire à ce que sa
part de ceux ci on ira chercher les
critères d'exclusion dont je vous ai
parlé
l'épilepsie la myopie sévère et on a
fait le diagnostic dont d'agoraphobie en
faisant tout ça nous avons obtenu 18
patients
nous avons ensuite divisés en deux
groupes réalité virtuelle seulement et
réalité virtuelle avec thérapie
cognitive
donc on avait un 6,9 bien sûr de chaque
côté et ces patients vont pouvoir
utiliser tous les deux la réalité
virtuelle et donc être exposés à des
environnements virtuels du lieu qu'ils
craignent avions métro parkings
souterrains le fermer donc voilà avant
de faire tout ça on va chercher à
mesurer la sévérité évidemment leur
pathologie ça c'est le médecin le
psychologue le psychiatre le chercheur
qui est très très sexy 1 et que vous
pouvez encore être avec le symbole si on
fait un pré test pour évaluer la
sévérité de la pathologie
à quel point ils sont agoraphobe parce
qu'il faut qu'on puisse se mesurer sa
avant de les traiter
on a aussi mesuré leur rythme cardiaque
ça permettait ainsi aux thérapeutes et
aux chercheurs de voir directement
pendant la thérapie leur rythme
cardiaque ce qui est très important
parce qu'évidemment cas de stress
le rythme va augmenter dans ce groupe là
il y avait la thérapie cognitive qu'on
faisait donc avant l'exposition c'est à
dire que c'est un principe qui vous aide
à gérer votre stress votre anxiété et
qui vous permet également de comprendre
que l'ong s'était pas trop lié à des
preuves de penser et de représentation
mettre le patient a modifié ses pensées
est-ce qu'on voit ici donc là c'est
encore comme comparer à l'heure voire
out of the box ou différemment les
choses
et une fois que c'est fait alors le
thérapeute peut débuter
la thérapie demande à la patiente de m
agoraphobe de mettre son casque de
réalité virtuelle
on voit ici alors évident pour le
mouvement se fait en fonction des
mouvements naturels mais pour avancer à
moins que vous fassiez votre expérience
dans un stade de foot votre passion va
toucher le mur dont il faut avancer la
fonction d' avance et recule et se fasse
avec un joystick
mais le reste des mouvements est
parfaitement naturel comme vous allez le
voir voici les environnements qu'on a
créé donc pour ces patients agoraphobe
vous voyez que les mouvements la tête
vont guider en fait l'image qui se
déplacent de manière synchrone avec les
mouvements du corps et de la tête grâce
aux traqueurs donc c'est la personne
radan ol va voir les nuages
ça regarde en bas eh bien elle va voir
bien sûr ses pieds est très important
son ombre qui est très très gros facteur
de réalisme si vous n'êtes pas votre
homme vous y croyez pas une fois que
c'est fait donc le joystick va servir
avancer reculer comme je voulais
préciser donc important pour avancer un
bouton pour reculer alors la solution à
ça c'est le tapis roulant
multidirectionnel
on sait les inventeurs parmi vous
allez-y ça m'intéresse très fortement
donc voici un premier environnement
qu'on a faits qui a pour but d'aider le
patient se familiariser d'envoyer ces
vivants et des oiseaux et les nuages et
la si jolie texture des objets variés il
ya des avatars très important pour qu'on
ait vraiment l'impression d'être
présents dans l'environnement et on
passe maintenant aux environnements
thérapeutique
alors lille ses patients à quoi bon
parent de prendre les ascenseurs ont du
coup il a créé les ascenseurs de trois
tailles différentes nouvelles idées de
progression donc le thérapeute d'appuyer
sur le bouton et les avatars peuvent
rentrer ou non selon ce qu'ils décident
avec le patient le passant peut décider
ou non appuyé sur le bouton et la rive
ainsi au bar au sommet le thérapeute de
voix en direct ce que voit le patient en
même temps donc il peut le guide est
justement et lui rappeler les différents
principes de la thérapie est d'accord
avons très peur des supermarchés donc du
coup d'affaires supermarché avait coûté
procédure on peut acheter du nutella des
séries
elle et c'est avec gluten bien sûr et on
peut faire la queue ce qui est terrible
pour les paragraphes hop parce qu'ils
ont souvent à des attaques de panique
quand ils font la queue voilà ensuite
les environnements suivants
c'est le désert car il s'agissait de
patients australiens dont qu'ils avaient
peur du désert australien si vous êtes
déjà allé pour eux c'est très flippant
vous trouvez ça dans le désert sans
personne sans rien on aime aussi fait
des pompes puisqu'ils ont très peur des
points il y avait trois ponts dont deux
tailles différents enfin toujours à
l'idée de progression le métro qui est
un le terrible pour eux parce que ces
souterrains parce que ces petits parce
que ces conflits parce que du monde ça
c'est infernal pour eux
les procédures sont encore reconstitué
1h utic est passé les bornes le métro
arrive ils doivent le prendre
le thérapeute peu con tre est longue de
personnes présentes dans le métro
évidemment ce sera plus facile pour le
patient si à personne après si vous
voulez augmenter la difficulté vous
pouvez augmenter le nombre de personnes
et vous pouvez aussi simuler des
attaques de panique en donnant un flou
visuel
souvent quand on est très angoissée on a
des flous ou on les effets
symptomatologie qu on pourra ajouter
aussi un effet de tunnels ou également
des bruits de battements cardiaques
tout ça pour exposer le patient à
l'anxiété c'est ce qu'on veut mais
attention avec douceur bien sûr les
parcs souterrains terrible saadé plus en
plus étroite et sombre
donc ça aussi c'était c'est un très bon
environnement pour les patients qui sont
claustrophobe ou agoraphobe le cinéma la
procédure est encore complète le patient
fait la cause de nouveaux doit acheter
son ticket s'assoit et très difficile au
milieu de la rangée car il est bloqué
avec les spectateurs
donc en cas d'envoi ce complément du
film il n'aura pas sortir et il ya un
vrai film à l'intérieur de ce cinéma
virtuel
cet accord avec moi l'avion à st très
grand classique la peur de prendre
l'avion c'est très fréquent et des
compagnies aériennes ont beaucoup
investi là-dedans
donc vous pouvez contre le nombre de
passagers c'est plus difficile il ya
plus de monde
vous pouvez contrôler toutes les
procédures de décollage atterrissage
présence de turbulences et donc votre
pinceau est ainsi exposé à cette
situation qui est très divisée à
considérer la réalité alors le soleil
est présent et descend vous avez donc
remporté vous avez nuages qui défilent
vous avez les panneaux qui vont qui font
saliver les annonces et en même temps
donc au moniteur également les
paramètres physiologiques tels que des
battements cardiaques
le stade ultime du traitement de
l'agoraphobie c'est la conduite
automobile
sur autoroute donc c'est ce qu'on avait
utilisé chez ces patients agora femmes
on les avait invités à conduire oui
alors c'est à gauche parce que c'est
l'australie bien sûr et et le petit
rigoureux si le plus extrême attention
c'est l'embouteillage dans un tunnel
attaques de panique garantie n'utilisez
jamais cet environnement là en première
session
sinon c'est l'arrêt cardiaque voilà donc
l'expérience ainsi l exposition aux
crédits virtuels et terminez votre
passion au pouvoir ainsi retiré son
casque de réalité virtuelle
alors on a cherché à mesurer les effets
après on a mesuré les effets avant et on
va s'intéresser aux effets qui sont
mesurées après pour faire une
comparaison et pouvoir ainsi témoigné
une amélioration significative ce qui
était le cas de ces patients dont on
attend un post est et tous ces patients
ont une diminution significative de
l'anxiété une diminution de leur
dépression et une augmentation de la
qualité de vie est très important dans
la réalité ils ont pu affronter ses
vraies situations aucun effet de
généralisation qui s'est produit dans la
réalité je vais arriver directement là
beaucoup d'eau parce que je vois que
j'ai peu de temps la conclusion c'est
que on est maintenant développer en
réalité virtuelle
ce qu'on attend c'est la généralisation
de la réalité virtuelle
c'est à dire la généralisation de
support de sorte que vous vous faisiez
chacun un casque de réalité virtuelle
chez vous et c'est ce qui va arriver
avec les casques de la prochaine
génération comme le culte rift ou comme
sony qui va sortir son morpheus qui
seront à 300-400 euros
avec ce média sera chez vous donc à la
portée de tout le monde
et du coup la psychothérapie
l'entraînement pourra se faire à
domicile pas seulement à l'hôpital
chacun d'entre vous pourra utiliser ses
capacités pour s'entraîner au sport à la
culture viser les musées de par le monde
virtuel et aussi donc traiter les
patients à domicile
je vous remercie